hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker we
have 45 lives left and six levels to go
so let's see if they're going to be big
bastards to me and I vow that was
something okay hey you guys stay out of
there it's it's still not your oh damn
it I only accidentally did that well
[ __ ]
oh this seems odd how whoa whoa whoa
Nelly what do you think you're doing I'm
not gonna be able to get one of those
over here so guess I gotta do slow
methodical wall jumps here how am I
supposed to be able to get the right
ones if goddamnit
I know I'm supposed to bonk oh that guy
how goddammit
just I'm not good at wall jumps [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off that is so stupid how else do
you do this god damnit [ __ ] me in the
butthole
okay well at least I got that I don't
know what's happening down there but it
better be good woah [ __ ] to me God
[ __ ] you [ __ ] off alright get that first
not that it matters I'm gonna lose it
anyway but hopefully I can move there we
go
okay I can get through yeah don't jump
that yet I don't want that yet okay
Oh what the oh I thought I killed him
for a second there and that would have
like really stopped me in my tracks okay
that's okay got him there we go
whoa [ __ ] off okay we're fine
everything's fine
this is go through here I got a one up
and that's good Oh what are you gonna do
to me well okay
I'm very scared very scared okay that
was very scary
you can understand my fear okay oh okay
all right we're okay let me what am I
doing here
oh I know what I'm doing okay never mind
I don't know I'm doing here Bob
am I missing something here okay do I
need you oh I might need this guy oh I
do need this guy okay yeah he's gonna
break the blocks on the oh oh hey buddy
hey buddy whoo careful there hey buddy
you want to play huh aah
come on come back come back to me I have
to get over you there we go that's the
right side okay now this guy's gonna go
and he's going to do his damage there we
go yeah he did his deal unless I'm
supposed to go over there what are you I
don't know if I'm supposed to change
that out but I'll take it just in case
okay I was supposed to change that out
but didn't matter apparently okay so I
need you oh [ __ ] off with that [ __ ]
okay that's done there get this again
okay that's okay cuz I can always get
more okay but now all of them are done
and supposedly it's one of these an exit
pipe
maybe also an exit pipe [ __ ] goddamn it
oh [ __ ] get off of me
whoa [ __ ] yeah whoa whoa whoa what the
[ __ ] was that all about
can I just whoa oh god oh god no get out
of there No oh that's scary
okay so one of these is the answer okay
I'm a little confused
oh they just need to blow up oh they
need to blow up oh okay
there we go okay so they just need to
blow up down there okay I guess it's
whoa what the [ __ ] I forgot I can do
that no that's not what I wanted
god damn it oh well that's not good okay
so as soon as that clears that off [ __ ]
probably needed that okay no no not
choices I hate choices he dumb I hate
choices okay there we go you say got
that back okay
what am I supposed to do about this this
is a long ass level no I needed that I
need that [ __ ] I needed that no [ __ ] I'm
dead yep I'm dead oh boy I did something
very bad oh oh but uh
but okay try this again without the fire
flower apparently
okay this time we're gonna go up it and
in in in in it in okay
I just wasn't ready for the door I
imagine all those doors go to the exact
same place hello can I have that oh boy
well [ __ ] off okay we got that god I
gotta got it okay so that door in there
might be the way yep it's definitely the
way okay go through here that's [ __ ]
okay so one of the it must be one of the
doors up here then well okay at least
I'm in the right spot okay so far so goo
come at me bro come at me bro whoa
didn't expect that okay that's not good
wait how am i how the [ __ ] oh no oh no
he's not gonna be able to get out of
there I'm not gonna be able to get
around him
oh no oh no well this is a conundrum how
do we fix this I think I'm boned whoa
there we go yes please okay so I made it
through that level okay that was
convoluted but not too difficult and I
had a lot of opportunities for 1ups it
took me a long time to get through it
admittedly or doing okay so long as we
keep the streak going and I avoid any
too difficult ones because that's what I
do not want anything to do with that
we'll be fine
fear The Walking Castle I don't know
what's that mean
Oh about it good boy
boink okay so now we get that here thank
you
I was hoping for that okay whoa that
doesn't look good ah there's bad it's
gonna run okay whoa haha whoops [ __ ]
I can't even hit these ah-ah-ah-ah
not enough oh [ __ ] okay so apparently
I'm not supposed to try to kill both of
them at the same time if I'm if I'm
trying to this is gonna be a [ __ ] I can
already tell there's going to be I don't
even need that to get this okay got that
OOP we only got one going that way oh
[ __ ] that was close loss hop okay
oh [ __ ] I'll wait for the next one wait
for the next train
[ __ ] how big of a doof am i the answer
isn't extreme hope oh wow
I don't even know how that worked okay
hope that don't look good oh okay I'm
trust me on this one okay trusted trust
is good I like trusting trusting is what
friends do and Friends is what I have
doesn't matter if you give me a goddamn
fire flower I'm still gonna [ __ ] it up
on the job
whoa Wow Wow whoa
saved by the yes oh yes oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you stay away from me you goddamn
burning for oh you [ __ ] me you have
[ __ ] me you [ __ ] me goddamnit I
jumped right as the cannon ball went out
and it it's off see just like that oh
[ __ ]
if I do just like embarrassingly small
jump oops I meant to do that
it's okay I guess hey-ho hey-ho hey-ho
yes yes yes yes okay yes yes friendship
friendship is best ship oh one true
pairing okay here we go
HUP yes please cooperate with me I want
to be your friend I want to be there for
you in your darkest of times I guess I
don't need to panic all that much
because it's not like they're gonna go
away if I keep jumping so I just got a
coordinate properly and then I'll be
fine
yes okay then jump immediately go there
I like the sound of this just be careful
and then boom you're done you're done
you're done
yes yeah well that feels good
oh that feels good oh that feels good oh
that feels good
okay I'm gonna start the next one and
then see how it is and then go from
there that feels good that feels real
good I do that pretty well not to toot
my own horn but I did that pretty well
I'm on level 13 I got 45 lives left one
mushroom one life so I'm assuming that
means I gotta get through this in one
try or else everything's going to be
okay I can do that
nah damn it there we go got it okay I
don't know if they wanted me to go this
way but it seems like what I was
supposed to do okay
is this the one mush am i one mush man
arc me okay that's a little odd am I
supposed to put this there wha [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] good God huh it's gonna set
this down because it's dangerous I don't
know how I survived but I did bunk okay
there we go now we got it ah okay I just
got a sneak through there very very
closely I need not be so frickin dumb
about things and panic cuz panicking is
what causes mop no but
no no no no what [ __ ] god damn it you
son of him why did it go in there I was
right on the edge dropping it that's
such [ __ ] I can get through this so
long as you guys believe in me cuz all I
all I've ever wanted in life is to make
you guys happy with what oh [ __ ] I'm all
over the place I'm all over the place
with nerves okay I'm gonna try it from
this side cuz at least it'll be a little
less dangerous okay well that's well I
wouldn't be able to get through there
anyway how am I supposed to be able to
do that
maybe if I grab this shell and I toss it
up no [ __ ] you god damn damage boost
what [ __ ] off with that
oh you sack of let's try this again with
the damage boosting whoa with the proper
no get go god damn it [ __ ] you okay
stay dead okay whoo so I had to be
damaged to go through there anyway so
that's good to know why can't I go ah
[ __ ] that's not what I wanted what would
[ __ ] this levels being a bag of dicks
this levels being the truest of dick
bags 100% dick bag area I mean it's not
hard the thing is it's not hard like it
it's it seems like it was just made
randomly and sporadically and for all I
know what why I did not do that what the
[ __ ] oh my god you just sat down right
there because what the [ __ ] was that all
about
it just randomly decided to sprint while
I was on that one little block here and
then it decided hey I'm gonna throw this
and why is it not setting it down
properly there we go whoo boy this this
one's testing me it's testing me good no
don't go over there
good stay down okay now this time be
less stupid about it that's not what I
want so finicky [ __ ] pushed on him I
coulda walked right and I would have
been in the clear bag of dicks bag of
dicks bag of dicks bag of dicks chant in
the comments everybody bag of dicks ah
oh no come back
No oh oh it's the end oh don't don't
[ __ ] with me here no more spikes or
something there I would have been very
pissed okay that's all the time I got
for this episode of Super Mario maker I
got one one up off of that because it
didn't cover the top of it to get in
anyway but thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
the cheese physics